[Music]
i'm with you i'm with you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
do you understand why i called you here
tonight
look
i thought we were good
it's all in the contract
no
you're never good with the devil walrus
[Music]
[Music]
you can't direct you're in quarantine
yeah [ __ ] you stephen
[Laughter]
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
channel
[Music]
speedy
happy mlk day everybody uh we work
here at lotto with crowder
we still work we also uh believe it or
not what's this with my head my
headphones are a little loud we also
work on columbus day ah well yes we
don't take any indigenous people's day
yeah uh and you know a lot a lot a lot
to like about mlk uh prostitutes crack
and orgies not amongst them no
we're going to discuss that today yes
well i haven't introduced you yet
he just couldn't help the surprise
spoiled the surprise joe lewis get in
your place he's even out he's like screw
this he's like this is a bad start to
the week so it is mlk junior day right
because often people go senior no
um they're like was that the day that he
uh nailed the uh nailed his uh you know
the day of the worm diet it's like
that's a theological thing no no we're
talking about i have a dream today that
guy that guy yeah so uh we'll be talking
about that quite a bit also some new
updates here on uh
not only covid but hey half of your
country wants to incarcerate you if you
deny vax mandates what terrifying
terrifying a little bit of a callback to
last week where i said hey do you think
for a second
that if we didn't have people standing
guard in this country checks and
balances that we would be australia we
would be canada turns out that uh almost
the entire dnc wants that for you and
this is important this is what we're
going to be talking about the theme here
today is uh
bridled power
and if you live in a country of
pacifists in a place like australia or a
place like canada
guess who wins the one person who isn't
a pacifist
that's the problem if you have people
who don't stand up if you have people
who don't say hey look this this is
going too far and do the right thing
guess what the person who's willing to
do the wrong thing wins
and we're just at that edge right now
and dear god i hope we can correct it
but before we go on i want to let you
know this is a live show every monday
through thursday yeah 10 a.m eastern if
we're not here on youtube and we don't
tell you
that means that you can watch it on
rumble you can watch it on mug club it's
going on we've just been suspended which
uh from what i understand right no
suspension not so far we haven't gotten
any facts yet from like cdc or anybody
else like that no no no no no
do not talk about the cdc changing their
guidelines to warranty for five days i i
would never we would never ever discuss
it so my question to you before we move
on to introduce everybody what do you
know about mlk junior
um what do you love about them what do
you dislike about them what do you think
you know about them because
i think there's a lot of you know maybe
put in your mouth guard don't let this
tin can i'm about to kick hit you in the
teeth there's a lot of info today some
of some of which was surprising to me
but before we move on and talk about the
rest of the news uh gerald a is here how
are you i am well sir how are you i'm
fine i tested negative for the for the
cron oh good yeah you tried to direct
from you know quarantine though so how'd
that go well it was about as effective
as joel schumacher directing anything
well that's true only i didn't have the
rubber nipples
and uh we have tim the toolmaker helping
on tricaster because in third chair well
we have two people ooh we have quarter
black here who's back even though i
don't know why yes like the kid who
still hangs out by the bike yeah he was
hanging out by the door when i came in
i'm like i guess i'll let you in it's
only been a week it's okay yeah it's a
cultural thing they just like uh hanging
loitering they just didn't show up late
though i'm running on black he is
running on canadian time and if you hear
that theme song you know that means that
he's here we also have in third or
fourth chair i believe uh where is it
where is it where is it
oh there it is
pops crowder he's in the place with
styling grapes he's really doing that
for garrett i think he can't stop it no
it's all over there you're ruining the
flow
pops
take it dave lando calls you a crawdaddy
that's your name
i like crawdaddy it hasn't stuck no
it doesn't i think it's stuck i think
it's a weird angle here looking at you
it's crawdaddy's season over here it is
yeah if you eat 50 of them you're still
hungry
were those you mean references there
well we work
oh no but uh good uh good thanks for
ruining my high school
thanks for reducing my reference to a
crappy bee comedy that's terrible what
was that was that no just saying we work
on mlk day sometimes we're like news
national holiday i'm like well sure yeah
you can be fired on a national holiday
it's a banker's holiday in a government
holiday sorry labor day what is it what
about the crypto uh miners are they
working yeah they are always i went next
time yes i was always working i went to
the bank uh-huh and the guy who was uh
helping me with my account was like yeah
i'm getting out of uh working for i
won't say the name of the bank i am
mining crypto ah i said what do you do
he's like i don't know i have computer
that mind for me
i swear to you i was like what are you
doing here you must have such little
confidence in this product he's like
this bad this bad not last long indian
fellow you were speaking not good
italian guy
yes from sicily
uh before we move on to talk about
anything else um i have not seen this
yet but uh tick tock is still cancer
and uh here is uh wait hold on a second
quarterback i want to tell people you
have your show too yeah yes i have a
youtube channel okay quarterback garrett
okay as well but uh i'm working with the
guy gary beakler on the nerd roddick
channel nerd talking about it weird
stuff okay very cool that's what we do
yeah well
count me interested the ladies like the
nerds hey
they do are we still racing on our
youtube followers to a thousand that is
correct no no i'm way past a thousand
i'm at 24. thanks i appreciate it we're
racing to a hundred wow
okay hey guys the thing about this
though is that nobody cares so tick-tock
is cancer
and here is further proof
this is my cover of louis armstrong's
what a wonderful world
it's a shame we don't just lock people
up anymore
[Applause]
okay so first off if i'm ever
prosecuting her for serial killing i
just go exhibit a and um i don't have a
b
yeah
i rest my case your honor i'm going to
jail gosh for crying out loud
i know and i know everyone complains
about the next generation
music or whatever but i mean
at a certain point where do you i mean
you're not scraping the bottom of the
barrel you've you've scraped your way to
china it's art
this is more like york it really is like
the 1980s zulu stuff and i'm like i
thought we were yeah yeah already yeah
never understand interpretive dance i
don't know
at least this is the mime i know he's in
a box he's climbing a rope but this you
know what what is she trying to do you
gotta have the clydesdales to drag there
was somebody else involved in this there
was a second victim here yeah
there's a hand that wasn't her hand no
everybody's a victim yeah
we are all victims so here's something
else i wanted to talk about this
happened this weekend there was a ufc
event
and uh the president of the ufc by the
way dana white here's the thing the ufc
was the only sporting event that
continued through covet we talked about
that uh puffs that it was a big deal
yeah they had testing they had their own
island and it was very clear that they
know what the president was just going
like this is this is ridiculous you just
can't stop yeah the world you can't stop
exactly the economy and of course he
caught a lot of flack and the ufc uh
overtook a lot of other mainstream
sports when that happened but here's the
thing uh
oh wait never mind we'll talk about that
you know what let's talk about this
first and we'll talk about australia
okay so um yeah you can't tease me like
no no no so dana white was asked
actually about uh you know this recent
controversy with joe rogan yeah
where 270 doctors were saying sort of
doctors sort of duck quotes
yeah like there was like phd people yeah
phd in philosophy yeah
that kind of duck yeah phd in philosophy
yeah oh my gosh someone's joking on a
plane do we have a doctor i'll save him
oh my god what are you going to do read
them kinsey
what's your relationship with your
mother
not gonna work
i've read freud i believe he wants to
have sex with his mother yeah and he's
dead well he was choking that didn't
help him at all
you just attacked his character he's
just gonna open the plane door in flight
okay damn greeks so
uh dana white was asked about this
letter written to joe rogan about the
doctors trying to silence him and dana
white not only i want to show you a
sequence of clips here because this
reporter who asked him a follow-up
question i know works at yahoo news i
think his name is ke i think the second
question you hear is from a guy named
kevin
yahoo news kevin aioli something like
that and uh
they try and catch him and then of
course when he responds on covid and on
the treatment that he's taken because he
did discuss this with joe rogan uh
ivermectin uh monoclonal antibodies
the reporters tuck tail so this is the
issue here they want to take pot when
they say hey the science and they bring
you nothing and you retort with science
they don't want to have a discussion
they don't want to have an argument
that's a perfect example again of having
bridal strength you need to have your
information at the ready these people
don't want it what do i mean by these
people the people who want to follow the
science the people who want to follow
the doctors and ask are you a doctor as
though your opinion means nothing the
simple retort is are you
we just need to be clear about this at
this point either we can have
discussions
or not and if you don't want to don't
give me the [ __ ] about oh we're
indivisible oh we're the united states
of america really how about heartbeat
bills no okay well then we're not
invisible we're not on the same team
anymore you want to kill babies up until
i'm including birth you want to remove
people's ability to make their own
medical decisions for themselves and
shame someone publicly for it so let's
go to the first answer and i do want to
note dana white has meniere's disease so
um he has trouble hearing so if you're
like if you think that he's not super
quick if he's saying what he says it to
all reporters he can't hear he's a
special earpiece the guy's as sharp as
they come here he is responding to the
fascist
totalitarian supporting press
trying to catch him on covet well how
about this
ever since i came out and said what i
did it's almost impossible now to get
monoclonal antibodies i don't want to
get too political and start getting into
all this but
ivormectin and monoclonal antibodies
have been around for a long time now all
of a sudden you can't you can't dig them
up to save your life the doctors won't
give them to you even when i did it when
i did it
here in vegas which was however many
weeks ago that i had it like right
before christmas i think or something
um
yeah i made one phone call and was able
to get to get it done and that's not
like some [ __ ] rich famous guy like
anybody could have could have called cut
that off brilliant
everybody could have got it back then
yeah and then even in the comment
section underneath this people going yo
you can if you're a multi-millionaire
it's like you literally addressed it
right there by the way you know who else
got it pops crowder sure
mrs crowder yeah uh-huh
i got it you got it yep it was very very
easy to get now it's impossible now that
being said it may not work against the
omicron because some of the treatments
that were effective may no longer work
because the mutation of the virus you
can blame the unwaxed i don't think
that's why we have all the mutations but
you know i'm not a doctor so he answers
here and then listen to this follow-up
where a smartass reporter doesn't
address what he just presented which if
we all want to
find common ground is entirely is there
anything unreasonable about what he just
said he just said this is something that
was accessible no one no one denies
monoclonal antibodies were effective in
treating no one including former vice
president biden including fauci that's
not one of those treatments where people
are saying oh we don't think it works he
was just talking about how it's no
longer available anyone here think that
there's anything at all out of bounds in
what he said no and this is the question
that so many people that had coveted and
were on
looking at going on a ventilator were
asking like can i please get monoclonal
antibodies can i please get some kind of
treatment other than going down this
road that doesn't typically end well my
wife my wife got it and she hit her
pretty hard she got pneumonia and the
first couple times we went into the er
nothing they just sent her home with no
treats
no not even not even tylenol geez no
suggestion on what to do right and it
took us we had to go out on our own and
find a doctor that would prescribe a
treatment for it and then it it was too
late eventually she had to go to the
doctor again the emergency room the
emergency room and then they admitted
her she had pneumonia and then they
treated her with the same treatment said
vitamin c vitamins vitamin d zinc right
yeah exactly they're going well this
stuff the stuff that is uh you know
witch doctor medicine why are you doing
it now well because she might die so
well something is better than nothing oh
well wouldn't that have been better than
before she could have almost died i
don't know man i don't don't push your
politics on me pal
and we should say too that monoclonal
antibodies free free right can we move
his mic in there a little bit uh i think
he's a little bit full they want to say
he leans out for the wealthy
voice no absolutely free and i think
i've sent a dozen people to the site
here yeah so here he is a follow-up
reporter trying to catch dana white
asking him a smart ass remark and then
tuck's tail and does not in fact stand
and
substantiate his own argument here you
go
are you are you surprised at the
backlash that people don't even want to
allow you to discuss options in
pre-treatment it's it's disgusting
we're not talking about um
experimental drugs or things that you
said this stuff's been around and they
got the ivermectin the doctor the guy
won the nobel
huh you're peace doctor watch this no
but there's plenty of doctors
watch it here he comes
no but i but i took him and they both
work for me so why shouldn't i be able
to take him again
or other people
i won't answer no no come on
throw the questions out
right you want to know what's scary i
bet i could get some pain pills
quicker than i could get monoclonal
antibodies
no not maybe that's a fact maybe that's
a fact they hand out pain pills like
they like their tic tacs yeah yeah
there you go that's exactly how you
handle it he just does not care are you
a doctor are you i'm not going to answer
that then shut up
no no no come on dive in
and he says maybe on the pain pill thing
oh yeah his industry is pain
he would know he wouldn't know wait a
minute
athletes get pain pills and injections
so that they can go out and perform even
though they have injuries that would
make the rest of us crawl back into bed
in the morning yeah but don't deny the
science and take a monoclonal antibodies
ah for the take another percocet
sniffles
don't take uh cbd or don't use kratom
that uh that could be addictive take a
vicodin yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
better for you don't take a leaf
opioids
doctor shop yeah yeah so uh this is just
i just
go send the guy some some support
because he's been catching flack from
those on the left of the the
i don't think that anyone can argue at
that point that you are not a cultist if
you think that that back and forth
went any way other than
complete verbal domination of someone
who's trying to be a smart ass but
here's the thing the left they don't
this is the thing with this show all
references are available at
lateralcredit.com right we talk about
this all the time we try to serve to not
exist in an echo chamber because we will
be attacked we're attacked constantly
the left usually just says are you a
doctor
checkmate no no that's not exactly how
it works you're gonna have to come with
a little bit more than that uh i won't
answer that why because you're a
stranger oh oh i think it's because
you're
because double standards it's
unbelievable
hey really quickly can we bring up cnn i
just want to i want to highlight this uh
this uk man thing that they're talking
about here with the uh the synagogue
thing yeah do me a favor too can we
bring up the name of the person because
that name has been released and the
person who's the name of the synagogue
synagogue
and took people hostage white
supremacist right exactly not a uk man
he's a brit they said very very
traditional british man they wanted i
guess fewer things like 44 year old uk
man we just just want to highlight
something here in a few minutes yeah i
mean interrupt no that's okay you're not
interrupting you can feel free to come
in at any point so they haven't
mentioned the name here on cnn no no no
they say a texas synagogue was a 44 year
old uk man all right what does that make
you think of what is yeah first of all
what comes to mind first mr bean went in
there yeah yeah
yeah free up and knowing terry went into
a synagogue
on the seven right
couldn't possibly be anything else
they're on the sabbath to a synagogue
not a random place that happened to have
four jewish people walking around
including a rabbi
a synagogue on a sabbath but he's a uk
man i've been to a synagogue on the
sabbath once i don't know if you guys
know this but it's positively crawling
with jews
lots of them you can't
can't throw a penny without hitting a
jewish person huh you mean and they're
making it they go to church on the
sabbath huh yeah synagogue i like it
synagogue that's true we'll bring up
that name in a couple they put it on
their website that no one reads oh yeah
well apparently you just pulled up
something that no one can read it's
completely dark screen sorry
you just pulled up his black lives
matter instagram post exactly
hey it's mlk day is it february already
yeah i didn't sleep today i've heard of
letterbox is that only box what is that
that you're bringing up
uh we'll grab it in a second yeah so
here's something else though as far as
terrifying uh i talked about this not
only last year but i talked about it
last week um
regarding the united states being the
last bastion of freedom when people say
oh you know we're we're all americans
and well you know the right has gone too
far do you want to know how far the left
would go people say the right has gone
too far right
compare ronald reagan uh to
compare him to anyone today actually the
writers become more moderate in a lot of
ways yeah the right has become more
moderate and the left has become more
extreme if you want to know what the
mainstream left would have in the united
states as it relates to covet as it
relates to your personal liberties it's
very easy just look at what mainstream
left mainstream liberals
uh what they've achieved in other
countries places like australia places
like canada places like the uk that's
what they would have here now new poll
came out that was shocking we had to
double triple quadruple check it it's
available uh link in the description
loudwritecrowder.com but first here is
me uh talking about this last week keep
in mind the only failsafe that you have
here in the united states
is
that there is still some semblance of a
conservative wing when people say uh
both sides no no one side wants you to
be forced into lockdown one side wants
the kind of concentration camps that
they have sorry quarantine camps yeah in
australia now i don't want to i don't
want to do the alex jones be like i told
you about this i told you about this
four years ago they had come up hey
human a humanoid kybrates okay
they are they are duct taping swine
scalps to rats and then forcing them to
mate with humans gay frogs
all correct by the way i said they were
turning the frogs okay look today brings
up a picture of just a frog in the
elizabeth
i told you come on colloidal silver the
signs were there i gotta have them back
um yes we absolutely do via helicopter
yeah club alex now here's what happens
to us whenever we do that i was not only
correct i just didn't know how quickly
and how severely it would escalate new
rasmussen survey just came out so it
doesn't surprise you 78 percent of
democrats support a vaccine mandate okay
we get are these overlays not working
it's just a black box guys i think i
think we had a black black box issue
yeah we have a black box it's mlk day
okay oh come on well let me know when
you guys have that fixed i'll read this
here from the map i have the overlays in
front of me i can just bring it up and
all references on the uh on the website
um 59 though of democrats favor unvaxed
people being confined to their homes
at all times there we go there we go
nice job hey
45 this surprised me 45 of democrats
favor internment
at special facilities for those who
refuse the facts that's basically half
half of all democrats and by the way
this includes democrat voters who think
that former vice president biden has
gone too far this includes half of
democrat voters who think that we're at
the point where we should be past the
curve this includes half of democrat
voters who think that we've gone too far
this is not the democratic party
representatives you know that this is
more moderate than the party of nancy
pelosi and aoc this is the voting base
half of them believe that you should be
interned you should be put in an
internment camp if you don't take the
vats uh the vats the vats they also want
that tax that's another segment this is
the whole reason that when we started
talking about the internment camps in
australia everybody was like oh come on
you're overblowing it this could never
come to the united states why are you
using that word voluntary dramatic
summer camps it's the summer of love in
portland it can be summer camps
voluntary
quarantine services
by the way if you escape there's a
manhunt well yeah but it's also not
voluntary that's the that's that's also
the thing what they do is they show up
they go hey listen we had a positive
test for covid and uh what we have here
is you can drive yourself to the uh
internment camp voluntarily or the
police car can drive you and you'll have
to pay fifty four hundred dollars choice
is yours it's voluntary and as well crap
do i have to watch the net it's proud of
the deal
i had voluntary summer workouts at uh
notre dame yeah they'll just cancel your
scholarship if you don't show up but
it's voluntary last time i made bad
shrimp i had voluntary diarrhea ah
these places have no stop gap there is
no there isn't yeah and and that's what
we're looking at so sporting their
constitution
no 45 of democrats favor internment
special facilities in a word uh that
means that democrats want some they want
this
so this i'm going to give you a warning
yeah it's an official warning
that you have to stand abroad and obey
the rules while you get yeah why are
these guys in a cabin that's right near
the fence
it makes no sense does it yeah but you
can't leave your balcony to go to the
fence to talk to somebody else that's
obvious yeah
no it's not it's not obvious it's the
opposite lines everywhere drawn yeah
you cannot leave your balcony and you
cannot go to someone else well it makes
no sense so it doesn't seem right to you
that is the line and that's what the law
is there and that's how it goes there
while you're here can we just do that
otherwise the next time it's a 5000
partner we don't want to do that it's a
five thousand dollar final
that i've broken the rules should be the
5 000. that's correct so let me just be
really clear here when we use the term
voluntary
this is a voluntary quarantine camp
where you are held against your will you
are forced to stay behind the yellow
line of your porch against your will
unless you're wearing a mask and
exclusively going to do laundry or
you're fine five thousand dollars that's
what voluntary looks like i i just want
to make sure that it's not comment below
do i have i misunderstood this entire
time the concept of voluntary i think so
under government compulsion yeah
voluntary yeah changing the meaning of
words you know you can't go past the
balcony it's obvious yeah right but that
was it's obvious what you can't go home
we expect to be able to
go for a walk obviously you can't do
that yeah
okay well you expect you're gonna uh you
know just feed yourself
ah a personal friend what are you nuts
no
you're out of your mind
[Laughter]
and look this isn't i thought this was
click bait when i saw some of the stats
on this come out i was like oh my gosh
hey guys take a look at this make sure
you research it and confirm this stuff
because i'm like there's no way that
this is true life and it is 47 this this
one didn't make it in there but i found
it 47 percent favor a government
tracking program for the unvaccinated
they want the government to know where
you are at all times you see that like
it's a fact
it is a problem you see that like it's a
bad thing look i can do that trick too
that kind of works like you can make
anything seem bad if you see it like
that like i could say gang rape no i say
it like that it sounds bad but if i say
gang rape
that's a little fun
yeah what it sounds like
it's like a good time sounds like a
party like an orgy that tell your mlk
would be it well you know i thought
australians were were hearty folk i
really did but you know anybody that
that acquiesced to the crown you look at
canada these people they're they're
different they have aligned differently
and this is the perfect test they gave
up their guts their whole society based
on that canada is the perfect control
test versus what we're doing here well
here's another stat been willing to give
up any right 48 of democrats these are
the democrat voters again so this is
going to be far more moderate than the
people in charge the people who want to
do it with the filibuster the people who
want to make it illegal for states to
require id to vote this is the voting
base so this is as moderate as you are
going to get 48 of democrats favor
fining or imprisoning people who
publicly question
vaccine efficacy
half of the democrat voting base believe
in imprisoning you if you question
the efficacy
of the vaccine which by the way fauci
just said everyone's going to get
omicron the freaking pfizer ceo or ceo
came out and said yeah it doesn't
provide a whole lot of protection unless
you get like the third or fourth booster
whatever it was but they love their
trucks
they love the trump vaccine that's crazy
yeah well it gets worse than that so how
many boosters do you need uh i think
it's 19. sort of like when people say
the earth is warm 0.7 degrees i go well
what's what what temperature should the
earth be
lower
i'm not going to answer that question it
should be the last scientist are you a
doctor stephen it should be yeah it
should be less than
0.7 increa it should be less than that
so you're not a doctor
okay so they believe in imprisoning
people for public questioning that i
know you're saying well this is just a
poll okay hold on a second where else
have we seen people be imprisoned for
questioning people be imprisoned for
speech people be imprisoned simply for
not complying well we have a couple for
you let's go on back to the outback but
yesterday things really stepped up a
notch when officers arrived it became
fairly physical fairly quickly and the
shop owner of 53 year old man from
wishart was arrested as people watched
on and filmed on their mobile phones he
now faces several charges including
obstruct police and also failure to
comply with a health directive it's
expected he'll face court in march isn't
it funny how that's obstructing police
but george floyd was compliant very
compliant yeah we just look at it
very compliance interesting it was
believed that he ingested a speed bull
before being escorted peacefully and uh
the police club them like a baby seal
like the inuit do but uh you know then
he tried to get off his balcony with the
yellow line what are we great we can't
have a society will just uh you pull up
the thread
and then in canada my horrible homeland
i'm i'm ashamed i used to have a dual
city ship i don't think that i've
renewed it i don't plan on ever going
back at this point i wish i could be
prouder of canada than i am it's for
life stephen i am ashamed well i don't
care i remember i reject i rip it up i
reach out i defend
yeah
i defect my canadians maple syrup and
any canadian who is not disgusted with
what's going on in your country right
now shame on you absolutely and i don't
use that term lightly you should be a sh
you guys should be i shouldn't say just
ashamed you should be embarrassed the
men of canada right now yes you honestly
should feel embarrassed this is
embarrassing for you because in canada
they do imprison here's that pastor who
was arrested this is like the third time
he's been arrested here you go
this is sick
you get orders from corrupted
politicians corrupted leaders and this
is what you do
ah what else went through their head
just like what's going on police
officer's head yeah is this what they
signed up for yeah like you hear that
all the time in these videos is this
what you signed up for when have you
signed up to protect and serve to arrest
what are you thinking of by the way
arresting pastors arresting business
owners arresting yeah just citizens yeah
people for walking their dog passing
curfew just following orders has never
been accepted never you're doing stuff
like this as a matter of fact i think
it's always the last line of the bad guy
the of the coward bad guy in the film
who's the second in command to the real
bad guy right almost all his last line
before he gets blown away is usually i
was just doing my job i'm doing mine
earlier about like some 40 of democrats
being in favor of a tracking system in
canada also from canada this is from
mission control the search is on in
canada for an anti-vaccination dad who's
accused of hiding his seven-year-old
daughter to keep her from being
vaccinated against kevin 19. the search
is what searches what in the hell check
the floorboards yes no listen i'll bet
you people had i would bet my bottom uh
i'd bit my bottom euro i don't know if
they use in australia
my bottom knife victor you're gonna find
that kid underneath the yellow line on
the balcony
it's obvious uh in the attic sorry
stupid cowards from a stupid penal
colony that's where we are now you have
to hide your kid in the attic so that
they don't get forcibly vaccinated yeah
well and here in the states we have
mothers putting their children in the
trunk of their car because they want to
quarantine them yeah you gotta hand it
to that pastor though you know you have
kids you know that little ninja move
where they limp yes and make them carry
you yeah yeah and yeah
you cannot gather up the goo okay that's
really yeah he's going it's like
it's like when you're trying you know
that thing if you get like dollar tree
the toy that keeps slipping out of your
hands oh yeah uncircumcised
oh wait wait wait wait wait i'm sorry i
thought we were looking at communist
china arresting pastors that was canada
yes just to be just to be clear yeah
okay i thought this was like a
repressive regime
known for violating human rights oh i
get it you're repeating yourself ah so
29 while we're talking about kids favor
removing custody of democrat voters now
29 so let's call it let's round it to
30. can if i may fair round it to 30
favor removing custody of children from
parents who are unvaccinated favor
removing custody just because the
children are unvaccinated and i know you
know we say okay that's happened we just
showed some clips from things that have
happened elsewhere but something like
this this is a bridge too far that would
never happen in the united states right
i miss my son
more than anything
it's been very difficult i haven't seen
him since august 10th august 10th that's
the day rebecca furlid appeared in court
via zoom along with her ex-husband for a
child support hearing involving their
eleven-year-old son now the two share
custody or had shared custody in
parenting time 50-50 she says out of the
blue cook county judge james shapiro
asked her whether she'd been vaccinated
she told him no she had not because
she's had bad reactions to vaccines in
the past judge shapiro then ordered that
she'd be stripped of all parenting time
with her son until she gets vaccinated
can i just order judge shapiro to be
stripped
oh my gosh wow
i mean think think about how that's
going to go
29 think that they could just show up at
your door and knock do you think parents
are willingly giving up their kids do
you think parents are really going to
let you show up with guns
drawn and take their children i think a
lot of parents will unfortunately yeah
and that's the pro look this is
something that i just discussed the
other day okay
and i think this is important because
the left tries to say oh the right is
calling for civil war and that's that's
not at all what's happening here
i think it's important for people to
understand uh people often operate
based on emotion or they can be rash and
you need to make sure that you don't do
that right you need to make sure that
you're disciplined but then a lot of
people on the flip side operate out of
fear out of cowardice how do you know
when you're doing that this is sort of a
litmus test that i use if something is
happening that's very emotionally
disturbing something that could
obviously get you let's say very heated
and you set
a dead you set a deadline or a timeline
you say look i'm going to sit i'm going
to wait and don't do anything rash i'm
going to wait two days before i respond
or i'm going to wait two days before i
make my decision and if you find
yourself not honoring your self-imposed
timeline that means you're acting out of
emotion that means you need to get that
in check that means you're not being
disciplined on the flip side
if you set a line in the sand
and you say all right you know what no
one can come to my house and take my
children
and then you find yourself not honoring
your own self-imposed
lying in the sand you're a coward if
then that line gets preached and you go
well i guess they're just taking the kid
to the camp for two days that's not that
bad the first example you're acting out
of emotion that's a bad thing but the
second example is just as evil you're
acting out of cowardice and fear you
need to put those boundaries up you need
to make sure you're not acting out of
emotion you're not just acting because
you're you're mad or you're sad or
you're feeling a certain way in that
moment you need to make sure you're not
doing that but you need to make sure
that there is a line and don't allow
that line to be crossed figure out what
it is or you're acting out of cowardice
yeah historically it never goes well
when they come and take your guns when
they come and take your speech when they
come and take you to a place because
you're othered for whatever reason
vaccinated jewish i'll say it sorry if
you want to talk about nazi germany in
the 1930s it was not far off from what
we see today
they even said they carry viruses yeah
they absolutely did it was othering
people but it's happened that was a
recent race right it's happened in
cambodia almost a million people died in
the killing fields there do you want to
just keep trying this it happened in
russia yeah the revolution do you want
to just keep doing this and see if it
maybe goes better this time right
because we would all look back at nazi
germany or look back at pol pot regime
in cambodia and say i wish the neighbors
had stood up for their friends but they
didn't right when the people came to
take them and they knew it was wrong
no one pushed back and i think you're
always going to find people that that
think that they're on the correct side
they think i'm not going to be affected
by these things whenever they get their
children taken away it's never going to
be my children right right well there's
always
it'll eventually get to them yeah yeah
and this is the issue too of bridled
power you need to find yourself
in a position of power and very rarely
exerting it because guess what if you're
not they come and take your kids and
there's nothing you can do if you're
weak you don't have
an ace and a hole to play do you
understand that this is something that
people need to understand you need to be
powerful you need to be capable
of acts that might scare people that
might scare yourself you need to be able
to you need to fear what you're capable
of and not act on it until that time
comes and i will tell you for me my line
in the sand kids
want to take my kids away
want to make it so i can't see my
kids them's fighting words
hopefully i'm not out of line
now uh let's move on from this uh mlk
junior day yeah junior i always need to
clarify junior yes because some people
are like
middle child
it could be the second no it could be
the second there was four i think i just
don't yeah it could be like george
foreman they're all named george that's
true yeah even the girls gina
that's not a great guy i'm not gonna say
george foreman he's unbelievable i would
love it in the show yeah
when people say that people can't change
i say george foreman i love his grill
george no well the grill is fine yeah
but then they weren't just planning on
george foreman by the way that's extra
that's on top that's plus that's plus
yeah that's how you see on the cake
you're right the reason i love this
grill is the fat goes off the meat and
it goes down and it's healthy it's like
you mean like all grills pretty much but
this is a battery well but you lose all
of the grease in the tasty bits and you
can always buy my grill at monica look i
bought it all right i was buying
this uh george foreman was if you he was
an angry angry man yeah retired became a
minister had a near death experience
anyone out there right now okay so we
have a most of you watching really a lot
of you young under the age of 25. so
you're
impression of george foreman do you see
him as an angry black man with a scowl
or do you see him as a happy girl
salesman one of the happiest people
you've probably ever seen as an athlete
celebrity that's how he's known that's
the exact opposite of what he was as a
person how he was presented as an
athlete until he had his actual come to
jesus moment when they say people can't
change i say george foreman so
i
unfortunately mlk did change as well now
let me be really clear about this uh
i like a lot of what mlk junior had to
say
uh i certainly think that his speech uh
has been
part of my language [ __ ] on by today's
left where he talked about the content
of character these were values that we
would all align ourselves with yeah
however mlk did become
far
more radical as life went on and there's
a lot that you don't know about mlk
junior and i want to be clear there are
values of course that he espoused that
we agree with but the man was flawed
like a lot of men but the issue here is
if it's going to be a national holiday
while you're tearing down statues of
people who fought against slavery like
abraham lincoln or even people who freed
slaves upon their deaths were done by
george washington jefferson then you
can't have a statue and you can't have
an mlk junior day because i'm about to
tell you
is a lot worse
i didn't know a lot of this yeah and
everyone the wife of mlk actually
gave his letters and all of his writings
to somebody at stanford and he
specifically
formed mlk in a way that would be
palatable
so he cut out all of the stuff that's
yeah all the negative edges right all
the rough edges so that's why we have
the and he advocated for the mlk day
right yeah okay well here's the thing
everything we're about to share with you
comes directly from congressional
records archived newspapers mlk zone
speeches and i know the fbi is not an
organization that i trust okay i want to
be very clear however none of the none
of the evidence that we'll be uh
providing for you here
has actually been refuted by anyone in
the mlk camps yeah they just don't like
how they obtained it right it was
surveillance transcripts reported by a
guy named david guerrero um but he also
uh uh this is the biographer he obtained
these transcripts from the fbi he was
the official biographer on mlk he won
the 97 pulitzer prize
so this is a man who was very pro did i
say you said 90 87 87 yeah um and the
fbi uh surveillance audio will be
released in 2027. i don't know why they
picked that year i have no idea
later you know yeah they're like oh crap
it's getting closer so um
here's something you probably know that
mlk for example let's start with this
support a peaceful protest yeah okay
uh that is true
sometimes
he also had some pretty i guess you
could say unsavory opinions uh about
riots that i do think
need to be considered because a lot of
people don't know this part continue to
say to my brothers and sisters that
this is not the way
to continue to affirm that there is
another way
but at the same time
it is as necessary for me
to be as vigorous in condemning the
conditions
which cause persons to
feel that they must engage in riotous
activities as it is for me to condemn
riots i agree with everything that's
that's fine i think america
must see
that riots do not develop out of fear
now
certain conditions continue to exist in
our society
which must be condemned as vigorously
as we condemn riots
but in the final analysis a riot is the
language of the unheard
what is it that america has failed to
hear
it has failed to hear that the plight of
the negro poor has worsened over the
last
few years
it has failed to hear that the promises
of freedom and justice have not been met
and it has failed to hear that large
segments of white society are more
concerned about tranquility in the
status quo
and as long as america
postpones justice
we stand in the position
of having these recurrences of violence
and riots over and over again
see and that's the problem is the
open-endedness to it because well what
is justice well right now people are
saying oh injustice is there too many
asians at uh stanford
so let's burn down a walgreens
specifically you need to be a little
more specific and let me be clear to you
at another 1967 speech and we'll get to
the crack [ __ ] and we'll get to the
orgies we'll get to all of that which a
lot of you don't know about nlk
five things you don't know about mlk
bet you didn't expect to hear mlk and
crack [ __ ] what
today i have a dream of non-crack hoes
at a motel six nope no no no i don't
think crack exists
i'm probably not just motility just
[ __ ] in general then
so a 67 speech king said
urban riots are a special form of
violence they are not insurrections ah
disagree
said the rioters are not seeking to
seize territory to attain control of
institutions which today they are that's
their stated goal black lives matter
they are mainly intended to shock the
white community the looting enables the
most enraging deprived using his word
here negro to take hold of consumer
goods with the ease the white man does
by using his
purse this goes on a lot if you look at
some of his statements regarding riots
and regarding violent protest yeah
it's worse than i thought i thought he
kind of both sides it he actually more
often encouraged violent protesting then
he discouraged it and that is probably
disappointing to a lot of people yeah
he's making excuses for people basically
losing their minds look i get it there
was so much injustice i have no idea how
i would feel but i probably wouldn't
then
go and burn down or rob a local store
owned by other black people in my
community and i would never justify it
and say well it is just as easy as a
white man using his purse well first of
all men and purses this was beginning of
the i'm talking about europe geraldo
it's not a european man bag stephen all
right it seems that he doesn't clarify
or he's flip-flops because there is
another interview where he specifically
says that riots are against the black
community because then they the same
thing that we've said before right in
2020 it destroys their own community and
it does the opposite of what you wanted
to do and he says
you you can you can kill a murderer but
you can't kill murder well uh pops
stoppers here those right the detroit
riots which you were alive
that really hurt the white man right in
his
purse we didn't feel it at all
not at all
but yeah he needs to whenever
he should have
combined it with what he said later in a
different interview yeah is it it hurts
the black community to do this and then
say they do this because that they're
because they're being oppressed
oppressed you know what must be
just as vigorously yeah is the farming
of your own community that's what
exactly condemned just as vigorously
think of the detroit riots yeah and then
they blamed what white flight detroit
right it's like well first off that's
not what happened second you burned down
your own communities in detroit black
people were harmed and you know who got
the worst end of that stick was
black police officers they had to go
home and unmarked cars because they were
being picked off by snipers on rooftops
there is you cannot find examples of
riots riots in the from the 1970s onward
that were targeted specifically let's
say against just white people which
would be racist but at least would just
make
maybe sense no it ends up hurting people
in their own community and that needs to
be condemned just as vigorously oh well
we don't find that writing maybe it's
because you were too busy with number
two when we're talking about things that
you may not have known about mlk uh
worked with communists yeah very closely
and i don't mean that in the sort of
sense of people like pink okami i mean
one of his top advisors was a guy named
stanley leveson
okay
and uh he was a member of the communist
party until 1956 and he secretly gave ml
kate jr junior ten thousand dollars just
one year after meeting him that's a lot
of thousands yeah adjusted to today's
dollars that'd be about eighty seven
thousand wow that's a big donation
that's a lot more thousands than i
thought it seems like an odd number
though yeah
i'm gonna give him 87 000 can't you
round this [ __ ] to 90. i have a dream i
have a dream to have a big purse yes
oh you like the one man white devils
with your gucci's and your michael kors
shock demons everywhere i go and your
louis vuittons i have a dream
so fbi counter agent carl prussian and
again this is from the biography just to
be clear so i i know that the fbi isn't
always a reliable source but i did tap
wiretap which i think is a horrible
thing yeah however we also have to
acknowledge the facts and reality as it
relates to mlk's life you see a
progression of him becoming more and
more radical some people argue it's
because of drug use some people argue
it's just famous corrosive to the human
soul but he wasn't the guy who a lot of
people praise sort of like i've talked
about this with muhammad ali
it's the flip side where people with
muhammad ali don't realize that muhammad
ali who was a draft dodger who was a
known racist who was against
intermarrying against race mixing uh
later on in his life actually moved out
to the suburbs and not only supported
ronald reagan campaigned for white
mormon orrin hatch oh wow but no one
talks about that with muhammad ali
people change if you change the wrong
way you'll notice there's a span of
muhammad ali's life where he really
wasn't a celebrity he wasn't given the
same kind of shine and then of course
when he died we go back to when he was
young when he would say he was young and
naive and ignorant how about the time
where how about once he grew up and
apologized for the race-baiting and
calling joe frazier a house negro and
uncle tom and he said i shouldn't have
done that and called sunny list in a big
ugly gorilla this is what muhammad ali
would do with people he said i was wrong
and i moved out to the suburbs because i
didn't want to be
in those communities anymore because i
have children yeah malcolm x same thing
later in his life he he was
he rethought his violence attack yeah
rhetoric he was like i don't think that
was the right way to go
and
being connected with the
the muslim church yeah
muslim brotherhood right yeah it's not
good it doesn't give you what you want
right so darren how many how many white
people looked at the detroit riots and
were like oh you know what they're
probably right yeah i totally understand
how many people from the other side were
brought to their cause and like given a
chance to see what was going on well
they had to see it through binoculars
well that's true what about what about
the riots in los angeles not the first
time but the second time that they've
been i believe they're burning down
indian village there's a bunch of
screaming gaming
it doesn't bring people to your cause
people hate your cause because you're
tearing down the city well mlk became
more rest so it's a flip side it became
more radical and so he's venerated
whereas when muhammad ali became more
reasonable they just sort of ignored him
for a while so fbi counteragent carl
prussian wrote in a sworn affidavit to
congress i further swear and attest that
reverend reverend martin luther king jr
was always set forth as the individual
to whom communists should look and rally
around in the communist struggle on the
many racial issues i hereby also state
that martin luther king jr has either
been a member of or wittingly has
accepted support from over 60 communist
fronts individuals and or organizations
which give aid to or espouse communist
causes number three things that might
surprise you about mlk uh not only
witnessed a rape didn't do anything
about it
1964 mlk watched as his friend a baptist
minister uh logan is it curse or kirsty
i don't know
rape the woman at the willard hotel in
dc a lot of you know this a lot of
people don't notes from david garrow
again this is the biographer and the fbi
surveillance docs show which will
believe be released in 2027.
the group met in his curses hotel room
and discuss
discussed which women among the
parishioners would be suitable for
natural or unnatural sex acts when one
of the women protested that she did not
approve of this the baptist minister
immediately and forcibly raped her
quoted directly from the fbi notes
surveillance notes
king looked on laughed
and offered advice
that's unbelievable and by the way just
to be clear the audio tapes will be
released in 2027. these notes right now
and this is what the author said because
he's taking all kinds of flack for it
nobody is challenging the legitimacy of
the claims
saying they bugged it that was the
biggest fbi abuse of power they've ever
seen because they bugged him and he
didn't know and they bugged everything
and then they started releasing things
to try to get this factual information
that they had into the right hand so
they could smear king that was it not
that it was lies right you can go to the
national archives right now anybody with
an internet connection can go and look
this up it is publicly we have we have
the links available and you have to deal
with it lightweighter.com references
available i mean
offering advice on a rape is um
almost shocking
i didn't ever say something yeah and he
had daughters too that's a horrible
horrible that's a terrible thing it's
funny how they're they're giving it 40
years from the date of the uh article
87 right they figure he can shine for 40
and then we're going to
bring facts out yeah it's all going to
be available in 2027. if we're tearing
down statues there's a big mlk thing
that we should probably go take a look
at and i don't know look i don't think i
don't know if it's as bad as abe lincoln
who fought against slavery you got to
tear that down but the man who was like
no not now now uh uh get on get up on uh
turn her around see well it's not like
roosevelt where he had the like in
positions of power a native american and
a black person
this guy had him and had her in
positions of rape well that's not power
well it's some say it's a crime of power
that's yeah it's not so much a crime of
power so much a crime that i want to
have sex and she didn't how do you make
a statue of that
well it requires a lot of iron
a lot of smelting
if he were to become alive skilled
artisans if he were to come alive today
to to his dream which is what people
focus on he would say we're here this is
it exactly what i imagined we were here
guys and then we passed it
yeah exactly in the 90s we were here
in the 90s my dream was never to play
the victim car card in perpetuity and
that's what what we have to do well we
also have the next one so if he were
left today i mean he participated in
massive orgies which um hey he would
have loved tick
to party
two-shit knows how to punch just would
have loved the talk
the following night this is after i
believe the rape in which he offered
play-by-play color commentary
mlk and his friend participated in a sex
orgy with about 12 people approximately
12 people how do you have an approximate
number if i'm at an orgy it's hard to
count this i would have an exact count
it's like the grid system you when
you're doing crowd estimation you just
you just
five feet by five feet and then just
kind of guess
what do i do count them as one and a
half twins if they're siamese it's one
if they're separated we will count them
as one and a half people
it's pretty musty in here yeah the smell
must have been bad when one woman shied
away from engaging in an unnatural sex
act uh kang and others discussed how to
initiate her and he told her the act
would quote help her soul well that's a
clever i don't think that's true he also
no it didn't happen but it doesn't help
her soul the advice i don't think is
true i mean i have am i being i have
something that will soothe your soul is
it the word of god
not exactly
better have a drink first
mlk also participated in another orgy in
las vegas with a friend a prostitute and
the gospel singer claire award what's
las vegas why do we know about this
supposed to stay there
well because she sang about it yeah the
guy was like oh happy day i had sex with
mlk he's like shut up [ __ ] shut up
garrett you're right the biggest point
at all what's going on good things don't
actually stay in vegas the next day he's
given a sermon and of course as we all
know as christians we are to keep our
mouths silent shut as it relates to
secrets
or events that have happened in vegas we
have solemnly sworn that it will stay in
vegas right clara right [ __ ] that's
right
my soul doesn't feel so i i didn't
promise oh
no money back
now uh
he uh king and ward watched king's
friend evan of course with with uh larue
gayle larue
i would never go back for another orgy
there would not recommend experience
yeah for sure that's the that's the last
time i go to that orgy
there were whips and stuff i'm not into
it it's just too much it's just too or
it was just too orgy-ish
there wasn't even good food and here's
the
that's the strip club they have a
fantastic buffet
and a wonderful sneeze shield
i tested it well
also i don't know if you know this uh
surprise uh mlk junior was a black man
really yes he was black what was another
little bit of a swerf uh just in case
well because i know the videos are black
and white but he was great yeah well
black and white so that's why i know
it's tough it's great you know what's
actually fascinating if you go back and
watch young joe lewis and sorry joe
lewis is here not you young joe lewis
the fighter he looks like a white guy oh
and some of them the way they color
correct it because he'd be fighting um
uh like jersey joe walcott or something
and black guy looks darker and you just
look at him and you know he had the hair
kind of part of the side yeah you're
like where's joe lewis behind that white
man
are there are there
lewis
this is not brought to you in
technicolor but uh he was black and uh
despite here's the thing despite all
these little-known facts about mlk i
want to be very clear this is about
consistency this is about if you're
going to tear down statues because of
something that you deem offensive
because people lived an imperfect life
then you would have to apply it to
someone who took part in rapes to
someone who was taking parts in orgies
to someone who was misleading about
working with communists right this is
something that we have to be consistent
about now i don't think
that we can't actually continue to
espouse the words yeah that mlk spouse
in his most famous speech where he was
talking about the content of character i
think that there are values there that
are worthwhile that are worth pursuing
and as a matter of fact i think today
the black lives matter community and the
woke left community who enable them uh
would be well served to heed the words
of his speeches as opposed to his
imperfect life but even when we're
talking about his speeches if to the
uh pops crowders points
if mlk junior were alive today and had
to give a speech that would get
thunderous applause from today's left uh
it would it would it would have to be a
very different speech
i have a dream
that my four gender-neutral children
will not live in a nation where they are
judged by outdated norms like their
character
but exclusively by the color of his or
horror z skin i have a dream today
i have a dream
that one day this nation will rise up
and live out the true meaning of its
creed fact checkers have determined this
to be potentially harmful and misleading
information i have a dream
that little black children and little
white children will stand six feet apart
at a pride parade to watch a man be ball
gag and bullwhip without fear of age
propriety i have a dream that one day
even in the state of florida children of
all colors and racial identities will
cover their faces to learn critical race
theory over zoom while dissenting
teachers are fired for things they said
online six years ago and are taken out
of context
this will be the day
this will be the day when all of
science's children yes yes when all of
science's children will be able to sing
with new meaning oh there ain't no other
way baby i was born this way i'm on the
right track baby i was born this way so
let's cheat em ring
from the tent cities of los angeles
uh-huh let's shoot em ring from the safe
spaces of brooklyn let's see them ring
from the tech firms of silicon valley
yes all right let's cheat him ring from
the branches of santa monica but not
only that
when we let schedum ring from every drum
circle at overland and from every
remaining apple store in portland we
will be able to speed up the day when
all of god's pronouns pocs and by pocs
latinx persons and chicon x yeah the
asexual and the aromantic allosexual and
section queers and the gender quiz the
lgbtq the lgbtqia
the
lgbtqia plus the
lgbtqia plus dollar sign
the sometimes questioning and the
two-spirited yes
we'll be able to join hands
and singing the words of the old
spiritual stay home yes stay safe thanks
science almighty stay home stay safe
spirit fingers please
i don't know which one i like more
powerful wow
impact impact
spirit fingers
too soon comment below
comment below if that's too soon no and
uh if you're watching on youtube right
now if you if you want to see more of
that smash the like button right now
right now just let me take an informal
poll if you don't if we don't have let's
say 5 000 people who smash the like
button before we go to mug club we will
never do another uh mlk schedule never
happens the rubber tip spear of comedy
that is so important i love it that's a
spirit i don't wear them
there's no faster way to ruin an orgy
than a rubber unless you feel weird
only losers wear condoms baby can we do
i hate to can we can we go to the name
of the person who the british man who oh
yes went to colleyville and and went to
a place that happened to have jewish
people
what's the name of the name the jewish
earth
british man malik
that's a british man what are you
talking about totally from manchester
probably united fan or does his friends
call him rusty yes
oh my gosh
and the theme for all while we're
talking about this again what would
what would be ideal when that man took
hostage right in the synagogue what do i
blown away for the rabbi
yes
for the rabbi to go death wish on him
yeah that's what i believe sorry not
sorry now i don't believe that to rap
the rabbi should go out and hunt people
of course not but if you show up in a
congregation got how do we know it's not
going to be another sutherland springs
which the media never talks about over
20 people were killed the guy who took
him out with stephen williford we had
him on this show first i don't think
i've ever been more uncomfortable
because i didn't i was like i think you
should take some time he was a mug club
member he was cathartic for him and the
media doesn't talk about the fact that
this guy
went in shot up a church and was going
to
he was driving to another church this
man an nra certified instructor stephen
wilford shot him dead to me i'm going
that's a hero we throw the term around
not someone who's a nurse in a hospital
that has six coved patients a man who
shoots a mask have you seen the tic tocs
though i have seen that they do dance
pretty i mean pretty effective yeah but
the idea is again with steven williford
while we're talking it's bridled power
yeah i want those jews in synagogue
to be able to protect themselves i want
them to be capable of such protection of
their most vulnerable such violence and
protection of people who are being taken
hostage
that they never have to use it
bridled this is something that people
don't understand we can we consider
strength to be toxic masculinity we
equate it with bullying
no no no what is the antithesis of
bullying
it's not being a victim
it's being able to be a bully and
choosing not to everyone out there
should be able to be a horrible bully
and you choose not to otherwise the
bully
runs the schoolyard
the bully runs australia the bully runs
canada do you understand how important
and actually you just went through this
we just a recent experience with talking
about joe lewis before we go to mug club
we're going to play a game that i can't
even say on youtube no um no no no
you were walking joe lewis uh the other
day pops crowder and tell the story for
people who who don't know this it's a
perfect example of bridled power well
first of all contextually this guy is in
complete control all the time and he has
to be we live by his grace i mean if he
flips a switch yeah we're all in trouble
yeah this is every single one of us in
the studio like every now and then
speed when he decides he wants to get on
the couch when he's not allowed and you
try and pull him off and either that
little deek you're like oh if he just
wanted to bite me there's nothing i
could do yeah better to just let him
finish
so i'm walking the guy of course he
heals perfectly right on your your left
side and totally in control always
looking to you for direction
and out of an open door shoots a german
shepherd full speed not coming
full-sized adult german shepherd
off-leash awfully open door right
and not coming to sniff and do that you
know get acquainted thing coming into
fight and so you'd always told me get
between joe lewis and anybody yeah
carolyn the dog trainer who's been on
the show is amazing she always said you
need to be an advocate for your dog yes
so that your dog doesn't react but your
dog looks to you and so as that is
pretty impressive that uh pop's crowder
is shot between joe lewis and a snarling
german shepherd yeah two scary dogs i
knew i was packing so i was safe
uh you know so i got out in front and i
screamed no and tried to get and this
dog went right around me like an awful
linebacker and straight to him and by
the way bit him i had to take him to the
vet and squeeze out some puncture some
puncture wounds joe lewis got bit pretty
pretty good so
then what happened this dog you couldn't
keep him off anymore no it wasn't
possible you were yelling to the owners
i remember you saying like get your dog
get your dog they didn't speak english i
don't think well they may have but they
uh they were immigrants who didn't know
about the leash law and just uh let
their kid let their dog shoot right out
of the house and couldn't control it
once it starts you can't no in the
middle of that fray
and in a nanosecond well yes you finally
dropped a leash once the dog yeah i had
a dog bit him yeah once the dog came in
hot i dropped the leash because at that
point i can't hold him back
and hinder his ability to protect me or
himself
and in a
less than a half a second this dog was
on its back pinned and yelping
and he had it at the throat but he
didn't bite it he didn't collapse it he
just pinned it and held it yeah and this
thing took off running he followed it up
on the lawn and so there was a a time
there where they were they were
separated and he just looked at this
thing and it looked back at him he went
in a second time and yeah
double tap and just pinned him again
didn't yeah he could have
removed this thing keep in mind they
have a bite pressure doggos of like 500
psi oh yeah it's unbelievable but they
they actually are bred to pin like born
cougar right to hold for the hunter yeah
that's their yeah they don't go to
consume something they go to hold it for
the hunter and um that was it it just
ran into this it wasn't even close it
wasn't it wasn't it wasn't even he
rammed the dog in his eyes the dog was
tumbling grabbed its neck and pinned it
and then you pulled him as soon as he
pulled the leash he came right back yeah
well as soon as i i yelled and when the
lease had to skirt through so i could
grab it yeah when it did i popped a
leash and said no and he kind of came to
his senses came to me and sat yeah but
here's what i remember we were sitting
there talking about it he came in and my
dad was just wired yeah i remember
you're telling me about the smell but
because both dogs the saliva is going
yeah you know um how scary it is
and
i was sitting this is a big german
shepherd a full-sized german shepherd
here's the issue
how many other dogs do you think that
german shepherd ragdolled until he ran
in to the brick wall that is joking
yeah that dog didn't even think about it
it was so cut it just no leash
just running rough shot over every dog
that walks by except for that one my
goodness and here's the thing joe lewis
has that you sit here and i was sitting
there going man if joe lewis wasn't joe
lewis
joe lewis is going to the vet with a
whole lot more than a few puncture
wounds and having to take antibiotics
right joe lewis might not be coming back
if joe lewis is a shih tzu joe lewis is
a beagle guess what joe lewis is at the
mercy of the german shepherd and the
beauty is before we were always talking
about it going do you think joe lewis
would do anything because he's so mellow
well now we know yeah he never has to he
may have been protecting me too because
i got in the middle you know i got
it could have been i'm very all instinct
yeah but that's that bride john defense
and that dog rules the neighborhood
until someone says no this won't work
sorry well and you need you need people
to behave like that as well right you
talked about having those lines and and
we were joking around saying like you
know what was joe lewis's pimp walk
coming back like i took care of that
he's probably like there wasn't one it
was probably like joe lewis was in a
life and death moment yeah and he was
confident in himself and his abilities
but probably wasn't feeling like i'm the
best thing ever right
that's exactly how i feel like these
second amendment like people that stops
you know a church shooter or a school
shooter or somebody in the community
with a you know active shooter situation
they probably aren't like i'm the
greatest they're like i had to step up
in a moment i could have lost my life
thank god i was trained and thank god i
did what i did but now i've got to live
with that yeah and that's not easy well
he didn't he didn't feel like a victor
he that was traumatic for him yeah i
remember as we were walking back he was
looking over his shoulder am i going to
have to go again and just you know i
think they just see and actually tell
them about what you were walking about
three blocks later that you ran into an
old english cop yeah and he said oh what
a beautiful dog well under control look
at that guy and i said yeah he was just
just got in a fight up the road here
with a dog who wasn't on a leash who ran
out of the house that's what we heard
that was horrible
hey malik you never believe what i just
saw and here's my poem we just we're
giving all references available at
loudspread.com we're going to go just
smash the like button if by the way the
rumble button if you leave a comment
below especially if you want to give
some moral support to joe lewis
um
when we're talking about half
of democrats and you know what's more
than the democrat party who want to put
you into quarantine camps
if you're unvaccinated who want to take
your children away who wants you to be
imprisoned
not just for not being backed but for
speaking out against
what might be the efficacy
which i'm not doing now but the cdc has
when you're in a country where people
want that for you to imprison you to
take away your rights what i'm saying is
this
they're that german shepherd out of
control running out running rough shot
and i don't want you to be that german
shepherd i absolutely don't but guess
what
i don't want you to be a maltese that
that german shepherd ragdolls i want
everyone if you're watching this show if
you're listening i want to make very
very clear my worldview to you because
we are entering a time where i think
this is more important than ever
don't be a bully don't be that german
shepherd but don't be a victim
be a joe lewis we're gonna go play a
game we could never play on youtube
youtube
you can piss off
you